wake up neo two hackers have been
charged and another two have pleaded
guilty to participating in an elaborate
international scheme to build a
counterfeit xbox one using data that was
stolen online i'm lucy and it's time to
follow the white rabbit in this gs news
update 22 year old david pakora and 28
year old sanne dode in the shaiwat have
admitted to being involved in a hakka
ring which dates back to january 2011.
during that month the group infiltrated
the internal network of epic games and
stole code for the then unreleased gears
of war 3. then in september 2011 some of
the team illegally accessed valve's
internal network and stole a beta build
of call of duty modern warfare 3.
another two defendants the 20 year old
nathan larue and 18 year old austin
alcala have not pleaded guilty but are
charged of acting in the conspiracy the
team is accused of hacking into
microsoft's employee network in august
2012 spending hundreds of hours
searching for files containing
intellectual property on the xbox one
which at the time had not been revealed
to the public or had even been confirmed
by microsoft assembly instructions
software designs and source code for the
next-gen systems were found and stolen
which leroux then used to build a
counterfeit version of the system that
console was then sold on to another
unnamed person who at the time was based
in mahe the republic of seychelles the
system was eventually sold on ebay
reportedly for around twenty thousand
one hundred dollars then in september
2013 just a few weeks ahead of the xbox
one launch two unnamed individuals used
microsoft employee data to break into
the company's redmond campus to steal
three beta versions of the xbox one the
hackers are accused of providing the
data to the burglars the cost of damages
associated with the hacking ring is
believed to total more than 100 million
dollars in intellectual property and
data and all of this happened before the
console had even launched yowza at least
we know from cam's reality tech series
that hacking in video games is way
easier than it is in real life for all
the latest gaming hacks stay tuned here
to gamespot